good morning this is breakfast thank you
for joining us
labor is aiming to force the government
into a u-turn over its funding to help
students catch up on lost learning
by demanding a parliamentary vote this
week it comes after the government's
education recovery czar quit
over the coved recovery proposals saying
the 1.4 billion pound fund falls far
short of what's needed meanwhile the
education secretary and the health
secretary are urging all students to get
tested when they return from half term
warning a huge proportion of new
coronavirus cases
are carried by children jemima walker
has the story
education says the government is a
pandemic priority
but it's also been a policy area fraught
with controversy
the unveiling of the education catch-up
plan was no exception to that rule
and saw the government's own school
catch-up commissioner immediately resign
citing a serious funding shortfall now
labour say they will force a vote on the
plan in parliament this week
to try and engineer a u-turn children
and young people
are our future we owe it to them to give
them the very best opportunities to
enjoy their childhood and make the most
of their potential
and i when i saw this proposal from the
government
i'm afraid i thought it was a betrayal
of our children and young people
a government spokesperson says we have
committed to an ambitious
long-term education recovery plan to
support children and young people to
make up for learning loss during the
pandemic
new research paints a bleak picture of
the extent of learning loss
with disadvantaged pupils suffering the
worst
nobody sees this picture more clearly
than parents
any mistakes that we make now in terms
of schooling
is something we're going to pay for
later it will have quite a big impact on
you know certain children where maybe
the schools haven't been so well set up
with their online learning and
things like that during the last
lockdown they're going to need to dig a
bit deeper
as we all have had to during this
pandemic
as half term draws to a close the
government is urging
all secondary school students and their
families
to take a rapid covert test saying
they've already played an
important role in keeping classrooms
open
the reminder has been met with
skepticism among some in the sector
for the government to remind us today
about the importance of that is probably
not entirely helpful given we've now got
hardly 24 hours before those young
people are going to be back in school so
it does feel once again
like a government on the back foot with
covered cases among secondary
school-aged children on the rise
some are arguing that vaccinating them
while ethically thorny is scientifically
sensible the pfizer vaccine has already
been used in kids 12 and under in the
united states and it's just been
approved in the uk
and so i think it should be rolled out
you know definitely in the next few
weeks in the next few months
before school return in autumn if we
want secondaries back the simplest way
to do it is through vaccinations
with british children having spent more
time out of the classroom than
any others in europe all sides agree
it's vital
school gates don't close again jerima
walker
sky news
meanwhile the uk vaccine program hit a
record number of first and
second doses last month nhs data shows
more than
13 million injections were given
meanwhile some groups have been advised
not to wait 12 weeks for their second
chance
officials say anyone aged over 50 or
classed as clinically vulnerable
should now rebook the prime minister
will call for the rest of the world to
be vaccinated by the end of next year
when he meets g7 leaders this week
boris johnson is expected to say global
vaccination sharing is essential to end
the pandemic
well the latest uk figures show there
have been 5765 new cases of coronavirus
reported in a 24-hour period
significantly up on the total on the
same day last week
but down on friday's two-month high and
there were
13 deaths reported which means the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of a positive test
now stands at 127 836.
meanwhile another 174 535 people
have received their first vaccination
and 360
691 their second dose
it means that 40.12 million people in
the uk
have now received a first dose of a
coronavirus vaccine
now despite the uk's successful
vaccination program coronavirus cases
have
increased in recent weeks putting the
june the 21st
final lifting of lockdown in england
under threat the government says it's
drawing up other options before making a
decision on whether to end restrictions
nick martin has been looking at what the
uncertainty means for those planning
a special event amy henderson has had to
postpone her
wedding four times because of covert if
the government delays the easing of
lockdown as planned on june the 21st
it'll be five times unlucky weddings
aren't being treated
fairly compared to the rest of
hospitality and other events
so the hard thing is seeing loads of
people at a football match
celebrating together or like more people
in a pub than would be allowed at my
wedding
sky news understands the government is
devising a contingency plan
should it need to rethink its roadmap at
the moment on june the 21st
social distancing mask wearing and
restricted numbers indoors
are all set to be relaxed some tory back
benchers are urging the government to
press on
i think the government's excellent
procurement and roll out of the vaccine
program has given it the luxury of a
very very cautious lifting of lockdown
measures
um i think the british public have
played their part
but if we don't get those uh lockdown
measures lifted on the 21st of june
completely
i think the public appetite is going to
wane very very quickly to comply with
them
covert cases are rising fast
hospitalizations and deaths
are not but the government is said to be
concerned
about new variants that could be
resistant to the vaccine
chancellor roshi sunak meeting g7
leaders on saturday
said the government was keeping its
options open no final decisions have
been made we're looking at the data as
it
as it comes in and as the prime minister
said you know we need to
make sure that we vaccinated and
protected enough people
to give us a reassurance we need given
the new
variant that is currently in the uk more
than 40 million people have now
received their first vaccination and
there's evidence that that's picking
up that could be down to a threat of a
delay to lockdown easing
government insiders say they're keen to
see all of the data
due next week before making any
decisions
about whether the much anticipated final
hurdle to freedom
can be overcome mcmartin sky news
and questions about whether the
government will stick to the june the
21st
lifting of lockdown in england a shorter
feature on this morning's trevor
phillips on
sunday this morning trevor will be
joined by the health secretary matt
hancock along with labour's shadow
education secretary kate green that's
coming up
at 8 30.
the home secretary priti patel has
written to social media companies
telling them to stop
posts that glamorize illegal channel
crossings
it comes after a tick-tock video showing
a group of men crossing the channel in a
dinghy was seen more than
800 000 times well harriet hadfield
joins me now from the newsroom and has
been following this story so what
exactly
is the home secretary asking social
media companies to do
well what she's really saying is that
when they see or spot these kinds of
videos showing migrants crossing the
channel then
she wants them to act pretty quickly to
take them down we can show you one
example of a video that was posted on
tick tock
[Music]
so this one's been viewed 850 000
times obviously showing a group of men
crossing
in a dinghy and the home office says
that there are many
other videos like this glamorizing as
they call
it making the 21-mile crossing over to
the uk and they say there are other
videos
on social media platforms and pretty
patel has written
a letter to the social media companies i
can read you
a little bit of it now she says social
media companies have made progress in
removing these horrendous posts
but they must act quickly and
proactively remove
posts related to illegal crossings
before men
women and children die in the channel
it's been an increasing problem uh over
the past few weeks 600 migrants have
been intercepted by uk
and french border patrols it's something
that pretty patel has
vowed that she is going to tackle she
can't blame the social media companies
of course but perhaps they can play
their part
harriet thank you
events take place in britain and france
today to mark the 77th anniversary of
the d-day landings
22 000 british servicemen and women were
killed during the campaign
which began on this day in 1944.
fraser moore joins us now from the
national memorial arboretum in
staffordshire fraser morning
good morning and it's a grey and
overcast morning so far today and i
guess that's
appropriate for d-day because these were
similar conditions to those that
were prevalent 77 years ago almost too
bad for the invasion
to take place in the end though
eisenhower did give the go-ahead
and we know that the rest from then is
history 77 years
is a long time to live with those
memories and today a hundred
veterans 100x service personnel will be
here to relive those memories
and to remember those who didn't make it
back 22 442
allied service personnel did not survive
the d-day landings and the subsequent
battle for
normandy and today they will be
remembered from the royal british legion
i have bob gamble here with me now
today it's not what was intended because
there's an unveiling of this incredible
memorial in france but the veterans will
be here to see it on these large screens
weren't they that's right
we're delighted that we're able to bring
them together not only to
uh to witness the opening of the british
normandy memorial
which as you say is just a fantastic
edifice overlooking sword beach
but also because for the veterans
themselves this is a really key moment
when they are able to come back
once a year and meet up with their
contemporaries and comrades
and and that's an important moment that
we we need to keep pursuing and the
royal british legion as you know does
that every year
a hundred veterans say it's an
incredible turnout and of course uh
virtually all of them i would imagine
all of them will have spent much of the
last year or more than a year
shielding so today is a very special day
for them isn't it to be able to come
together
that's right and obviously there's been
a fair amount of effort put into
making sure that all the social
distancing and aspects are
are provided as well as some cover while
they're here but the fact of the matter
is
once they arrive and they are together
as you will see when they do the wreath
laying
the reality is uh the most important
thing is that they're able to reconnect
okay well bob thank you very much for
talking to us i know you're very busy
today
to make this event happen so a hundred
veterans here from
those d-day invasions will be
commemorating this watching the
unveiling
of this incredible memorial overlooking
one of the beaches where the allied
troops landed 77 years ago
today it will be an emotional today a
day today will be a very moving day
today
and it will be a day of remembrance
indeed fraser thank you
well let's return now to one of our top
stories a warning from the government
that it's drawing up other options on
plans to lift the lockdown on
june the 21st that created uncertainty
for
couples planning to get married i'm
joined now by sean holmes and daniel
whiteley
whose big day is meant to be june the
25th good morning to you and
good to see you so how long have you
been planning your
big day first of all
good morning julian well we chose our
dates um
two years ago after we got engaged in
february 2019 so it's been
a long time coming for us but most of
the details
that we've been planning recently have
only been in the last three or so months
we've just been
unable to plan uh since
uh the first lockdown was imposed and
then when the government announced its
roadmap
a couple of months ago that's when uh
we're really getting our head been
getting our heads
back into it so uh there's still a lot
to do and a very short space of time to
do it yeah and sean it must be really
frustrating for you because um
as i understand it your guest list is is
over the the 30
um stipulation so what does that mean do
you have to uninvite
people and well
exactly really we're in a really
difficult um situation
um if we're told the numbers are reduced
11 days before our wedding
and the question for us is who who on
earth do we decide who can and can't
come
we've only got 54 guests anyway for the
day
and it's what i would describe as a
small intimate event and everyone's
already been invited
and we've made and we've paid for a
table plan
and which we've got behind us um with
everyone's names on
and um how on earth do we decide do we
uninvite our dearest friends since she's
known since school
do we ask aunties and not uncles i've
got a 90 year old auntie who's been
looking forward to this for
two years now she's safely on the list
of definites but still the point remains
how on earth
do you decide so late in the day and how
do you tell people it's just so
difficult when everyone's so special to
us
yeah i know very very difficult indeed i
can see behind you that that hashtag
what about
weddings um daniel i mean that that is
the issue that that you believe
weddings are being treated unfairly in
in the scale of things
that's exactly right you know and it's
not just an issue for
couples like us there are a thousand of
them up and down the country i think the
wedding sector's estimated that there's
going to be around
uh how many weddings in the first 50 000
50 000 weddings in the first month
after the easing of restrictions is
supposed to take place
so there's couples to think about first
of all but it's not just them it's also
their loved ones their friends and
family who've committed to dates to
travel to accommodation
and it's the thousands of suppliers
within the sector
who've invested millions in this sector
billions even in the expectation that
they'll be having events
to cater for to provide flowers to
provide
a the equipment it's a huge sector worth
billions for the uk economy but the main
thing
that we are looking for is not a
complete opening up so that people can
have
massive events big parties it's not
about that at all
it's about parity for this sector it's
about
proportionality and fairness for
a sector that covers really important
intimate life events
uh in for families and
about there being equality between the
wedding sector
and the other sectors that have already
seen an easing of restrictions including
hospitality retail recreation sport
you know we have seen so to interrupt we
have seen the recent pilots of mass
events with the
raves and and and people that being
quite successful actually are not
that many people actually testing
positive post the event
but in terms of your wedding would you
be able to guarantee
social distancing i mean do you think it
would be covert
safe sean absolutely there's there's
ways that we could work with the venue
to make sure that it's coveted safe
um social distancing yes and there's
testing as you write reports out
point out the pilot events that recently
took place and not far from was in
liverpool
which the health chief said um on the
25th of may i think it was
that there was no detectable spread
after that that used testing
all of our guests would be happy to
undertake tests 100
percent of our guests would have been
vaccinated 50
of our guests over 50 will have been
doubly jabbed
and so we just can't see why the wedding
sector can't just be trusted
to conduct these weddings safely and the
point is i think julian
is that the government hasn't even
addressed weddings when discussing
the recent the upcoming restrictions the
government hasn't said anything to us
about weddings it hasn't even mentioned
them even the scientists that are
rightly sharing information sharing data
haven't actually mentioned weddings uh
it seems as if these suggestions that
are being made by couples in the sector
are just being ignored
and i don't know why and it's really
worrying especially when
if i can point out this is a female-led
industry and i just question why we're
still being ignored really
well listen shauna and daniel um i wish
you the best for your wedding and really
hope that it goes ahead as you have
planned it to
um good luck thank you julian thanks
time now to take a look at the weather
for you with kirsty how's it all looking
do you know it's not too bad i know we
had some glorious heat earlier on in the
week maybe a bit too hot
and now we still have a little bit of
sunshine around it's still warm for many
but that heat could trigger
a few more showers
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for many of us there will
be sunny spells today
but a few showers to watch out for
especially in
this south it's quite gray first thing
today across parts of
southwest england up through the
midlands east wales in towards yorkshire
quite a lot of cloud around and some
patchy light rain
could be some heavier showers in the
southwest later elsewhere largely
dry and bright start to the day and i
think for scotland northern ireland and
the republic holding on to the driest
and brightest weather
just a small chance of a shower it is
however warmer more humid feeling across
east anglia and the southeast
and here we could see some quite heavy
possibly thundery
slow-moving showers through the
afternoon most of the showers will move
northwards and start to fade away
tonight tomorrow a great start
showers in the east back with me now
broadcaster and diamond and the editor
of the sunday express
michael booker to take us through the
newspapers once again
starting with you michael first of all
and tell us why uh
prince william should be rescuing the
union or being called in to rescue the
union
this is according to the title well this
story is my favorite and a royal word in
the intro it mentions cortiers
those mysterious people who crop up and
royal things with
they're doing doing these sneaky little
things now they want prince william
uh to and kate the duchess of cambridge
to spend a lot more time up in scotland
uh particularly in balmoral and saint
andrews
to try and save the union they say they
believe that is a union of crowns rather
than
something political they believe god's
this that the politicians are losing the
union at the moment
and and uh they're quite upset about it
uh and they believe that by spending a
bit more time
up in scotland like uh with the tour
that kate and william did
recently uh that they will be able to uh
help
sealer if there is an another move to
another referendum now
you know it's all well and good but i
just think that you know first of all
we've got this political battle but
to a lot of people to a lot of the
fairly normal scottish people that think
well hold on now we've got
a king the next or one of the future
kings
trying to get involved someone totally
unelected i don't know i could see this
this could actually backfire in many
ways to to a lot of people
they won't want to leave the monarchy uh
putting their tanks on the lawn
the other thing is as well if you're
going to spend more time in balmoral and
saint andrews
it's not exactly governed or going to
see a band at glasgow's barylands is it
it doesn't exactly what
normal people do so i can i don't know i
can almost see this riling some people
but um it does also towards the end of
this story show that there is a slight
disconnect now between the royal family
and boris johnson particularly
personally
given that they're saying that it's
interesting and key
that uh the queen still hasn't had a
face-to-face meeting
even though some of the pandemic rules
have sort of uh have
been loosened and that's going back to
when he prorogued parliament according
to this so there is a bit of frostiness
between the royals and the government
and you're nodding your away on this one
well i was thinking as well that one day
prince william will be prince of wales
not scotland um and i just wonder how
that go down with them so i
agree with mick i think you know it
could back further
uh let's look at something completely
different now in the telegraph
and this story about trojan puppies um
carrying a disease that can spread to
humans
well i think we all know that during
lockdown many many people went out and
bought a puppy
without too much thought about where
they came from and apparently during
lockdown year we in this country
imported and those are only the ones we
know about
30 000 puppies from romania
and a lot of them street puppies if you
like
and an awful lot of them carrying this
nasty disease called brucellosis
which frankly we haven't heard of in
this country for a long time
it's really fatal for dogs it's a
horrible disease for dogs
and humans can catch it too and for
humans if they catch it it can be
treated with antibiotics
but it's never really got rid of you
live with its problems
so it's a very nasty disease to be
importing which is why they're calling
them trojan puppies here
so if anyone still fancies the idea of a
puppy to get them through the you know
after effects of the pandemic or
whatever
you know be careful where you buy one
from because uh they could be a
puppy carrying brucellosis yeah i had no
idea we'd imported so many uh puppies
that's a huge
huge number to the uh express
now michael uh and this continuing story
about uh
generation lockdown as they're being
called and the the catch up how they
catch up in terms of
education yeah we've got gavin
williamson who's done an
uh op-ed for us uh today and
again um he's he's had a bit of a tough
week obviously we
we had to kevin collins uh quit um quite
very publicly with a quite a damning
statement against the government about
how
they weren't putting the funding that he
wanted in there now in the op-ed
uh um the education secretary
he says he says it will take time we
need there's under no illusions we do
need a long-term plan
so he is very very unspecific uh in what
he says
uh he's trying to say the right thing
but it is slightly
vague but there is uh quotes in there
from ellen townsend uh who's uh
a professor of psychology now she's done
a lot of work
on uh with this uh on this subject
with the express during the pandemic and
she says we should be under
no illusion about this that kids you
know that there is an
endless source of resilience that kids
have they need help that you know the
mental health has suffered hugely
not just their education and there needs
to be a focus
on them there's the there is this idea
that the focus is quite easily put on
uh furlough and business and things like
that and it's that and it's quite
noticeable that the government
likes to talk about that but with
education she says they're not coming up
with the goods and
i think a lot of people will think that
she's entirely right there's another
story
uh knocking around about gavin
williamson in the purpose today saying
that
the government would uh would like to
reshuffle him but unfortunately
he uh he spent some time with boris
johnson
uh during his leadership campaign in
2019 and apparently
saw some things which is uh i think
that's called for
i know where the bodies are buried may
hmm interesting interesting uh this uh
next story in the time zone intriguing
how astronomers
could help in solving the mysteries of
cancers
this is extraordinary and difficult to
understand let alone explain but
uh it says here astronomers are teaming
up with the nhs to solve the mystery of
cancer patients
whose tumors can't be traced apparently
thousands of people every year
are diagnosed with cancer but then told
there's complication
because doctors don't know where it
started they find the tumors at a late
stage
but they cannot find the tr the cause
the primary cause of the cancer
it's known as cup which is cancer of an
unknown primary
so they've teamed up with a load of
astro scientists
from durham university and they're using
what they call astro statistics
which is basically the statistical way
they model
for an awful lot of data that they can't
understand
so you've got a team of expert
astrophysicists
teaming up with the cancer experts and
apparently together
they can they can go through all this
data at super fast speed
and try and find out where those primary
cancers
exist isn't that fascinating it is it is
i think i need to read up a bit more on
it i still
don't quite understand the intricacies
but um yes
fascinating fascinating story um just
time for this last one
in the mail michael tell us why
naturists want us to put our clothes on
well they're trying to make some money
in naturists now this story proves a
couple of things i think
they've got a clothing line out which
you would think would uh slightly
wrong-headed but
they've got some slogans on there with
things like i'd rather be naked and
clothing is optional which
shows that they don't have clothes and
they don't have a sense of humor as well
uh but according to this uh apparently
uh
in lockdown naturism or new uh been nude
has uh has boomed apparently but not not
in this studio
and i i'm sure you'll both stay fully
clothed thanks so much see you soon